protests against newly confirmed Supreme
Court justice Brett Kavanaugh were held
in several major cities over the weekend
thousands demonstrated in places like
Seattle Denver right here in New York
and Washington DC Judge Cavanaugh you
know was confirmed after he strongly
denied allegations of sexual assault now
this comes one year after New York Times
investigative reporter that's Jodi
Kanter co-wrote the very first story
revealing sexual assault allegations
against Harvey Weinstein this report
fueled the me2 movement and the New York
Times won a Pulitzer Prize for its
reporting over the weekend Cantor
co-wrote in The Times
we have only one firm prediction this
discussion over harassment and assault
has no end in sight
Jodi Cantor's also by the way we're
happy about this a CBS News contributor
so we always like Jodi when you come to
the table let's start with judge
Cavanaugh because I think most people
don't think of the me2 movement as a
political issue it seemed it was right
or wrong men and women now it seems to
become a political issue has it or I'm
asking the question has it become a
political issue well these issues are
inherently political but also there is a
special quality I think to the political
stories over time not just recently
about sexual misconduct Bill Clinton
Clarence Thomas now Brett Kavanaugh
president Trump these take on all of the
partisan anger all of our worry about
the future of the country in some ways
they are the most important stories
because they're about the presidency and
the Supreme Court but they're also the
hardest because they're about so much
more villainous partisan lines though
and well that's the frustratingly
predictable thing
what what what helped special in many
ways about the me2 movement in the last
year about the Weinstein story The
O'Reilly story etc etc is that they did
not split along partisan lines the
message was this is a problem everywhere
no matter who you are no matter what you
believe politically this is all
something we we need to confront
together as a society now it feels a
little bit with Kavanagh like that
togetherness is splitting and falling
apart well it's an issue that requires
nuanced and careful understanding and
politics in when it said is most
successful squeezes out all
once makes things blunt and uses them as
a hammer I wanted to get your sense Jody
of an evolution that I saw that I
thought was interesting and when John
Cornyn and Texas senator came out of
hearing dr. Ford's testimony he said
well there were gaps in the testimony
but then he quickly said but that's
because when you have trauma there are
gaps he seemed to be very sensitive to
that idea then President Trump a week
later is on the stump in a rally making
light of the gaps the reason this is
important of course is for sexual
assault survivors or people who've been
through it the gaps mean it doesn't it
means you're not listening you're not
believing them if you say well you have
gaps in your story absolutely if you
look at dr. Christine glassy Ford's
testimony for a lot of people the power
was that she stood up before the country
and she said this thing happened so many
years ago but it still matters and no I
don't have perfect evidence and a ton of
documentation and no I can't tell you
everything about that night but I am
clear on what happened and I'm gonna
tell you other people responded the
opposite way and said what do you mean
you have no evidence what do you mean
you have no documentation he's being
falsely accused Joe do you have people
in the Senate a lot of people are
talking about Susan Collins on this
where they said well something happened
to her but it wasn't Brett Kavanaugh
where she said I'm 100% certain what
message does it send to survivors if
even when you speak up and you're
telling your truth and you say you're
100% because they knew each other and
you're not to be believed what senator
Collins said and President Trump said
something very similar it's not even
logically consistent because senator
Collins on Saturday said there wasn't
enough evidence for me to vote against
him but then she sort of raising a
theory that dr. Ford is misremembering
this and and that it was really somebody
else Kevin what evidence to senator
Collins have for that theory that she
just floated on television you know Jodi
you and Megan wrote about this mate
perhaps it's time to start thinking of
this less as a news story than as a
permanent news element of our lives
that's probably the way we're going
thank you very much for being here